The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Tonight is
a deep dive into DARPA, which
is a very different model.
And we've talked
around DARPA, but--
we talked about snippets
of some of the stuff
that we're going to
be going through,
but tonight will be
kind of a deep dive
into looking this model.
And the model is
an important one
because we've gotten
so much out of DARPA.
It's been a remarkable run.
And so we'll look at
the foundational period.
And there are a lot of
good MIT stories in here,
which we'll get on the table.
But we'll also try
to frame really
how this organization,
institution functions.
So this is a JCR
Licklider story--
one of MIT's all-time greats.
And he doesn't get talked
about that much at MIT,
but he really is foundational.
And he comes in at a time when
computing is really completely
different than it
is today, and is
able, with his team at DARPA,
to really work through--
really in an intergenerational
between DARPA program manager
and office director
generations--
really rework the entire sector.
So we've talked a little about
Whirlwind and SAGE earlier.
And just to remind
you, this was one
of the foundational
early computer systems.
This was MIT's at
Whirlwind and SAGE.
And this is Jay Forrester, and
he's holding the magnetic core
memory that he and one
of his graduate students
came up with, which enabled
real-time computing,
a really critical advance.
And you start to see at
Whirlwind, in the upper-left--
which merges into
the SAGE system--
you start to see where
computing is going.
So that picture of
this computer operator,
this lady sitting in front of a
keyboard in front of a cathode
ray screen.
That's this, and there it is.
There it is at late '40s, early
'50s when this is going on.
And how did this all evolve?
So on the lower left
is George Valley,
who was an MIT faculty member.
He was part of the Rad Lab.
And Valley is on a scientific
advisory board to the Air
Force, and he sounds the
alarm, essentially alerting
the Air Force and frankly,
the military in general,
that the Soviet Union has
developed a long-range bombing
aircraft.
They have nuclear weapons,
and they have, therefore,
first strike capability.
There is absolutely
nothing in their way
of reaching the northern
part of the United States.
And that's a terrifying
realization moment.
So Valley gets the Air Force
mobilized around an air defense
mission.
And computers are going
to be at the heart of it.
And he goes to
Jay Forrester, who
was developing this Whirlwind
system for the Navy.
The Navy's is
canceling Whirlwind,
so Valley just moves
Forrester and the team,
and the Whirlwind system over to
the SAGE project of developing
an air defense and controllers.
And the picture here is what--
essentially what
the picture looks
like of all these
different defense
systems, from early missiles,
and artillery, and fighter
aircraft, all being linked into
a communications and computer
system.
And then fascinatingly,
the communications lines
are across phone lines.
So the computers are running a
communication system that comes
into them across phone lines.
The picture of those
Air Force airmen
sitting in front of
cathode ray screens,
they're holding
this peculiar thing.
It's a light gun.
It's the mouse.
So you start to see these iconic
pictures of where all this
stuff that we just live with--
where it all starts-- come from.
And a lot of it came from the
Whirlwind and SAGE systems.
MIT doesn't want to go into
the business of manufacturing
computers.
They make the initial
computers for the SAGE system,
but they don't want to be in
the computer manufacturing
business.
So the SAGE system becomes
the IBM 700 series.
This is how IBM really
starts to scale up
in mainframe
computing, and starts
building the computing systems
for this air defense system.
So again, it's an example of
long-term patient military
support for
technology development
that we've seen before.
And here it is again,
only this time,
it's sponsoring computing.
So Mitch Waldrop's book
The Dream Machine I think
is really the classic on the
evolution of the Information
Age.
It is full of wonderful
stories, and I
feel that it's
really well written,
and I couldn't resist
giving you a big dose of it.
But there's a lot of great
MIT stories in here, but lots
of great stories about the
foundation of where computing
came from and how it arrived--
that fits with the material that
we've been covering in class.
So we'll go through
some of this key stuff,
and then stuff will
lead us in some Q and A.
Computing before Licklider, it's
non-interactive, it's not fun,
it's not exciting.
It's behind glass
walls, and you'd
be met by like these high
priests and priestesses who are
wearing white coats and gloves.
And you'd carry your
stack of punch cards in,
and you'd hand over this
offering of punch cards.
Maybe the high
priest or priestess
paid attention to you, and
took the cards from you
in a few minutes.
Maybe that happened.
And then they would
tell you, fine.
You're 479th on line,
come back in a week
and we'll have run this for you.
This is not real-time computing.
That's literally
the way was like.
It was just very forbidding.
It was very distant.
It's definitely not
what we have now.
And it's built for a number
of processing bureaucracies,
and initially in government,
but then in business.
And that's not to
knock mainframes.
They're a huge remarkable
technical advance.
IBM starts to
dominate that sector,
and they incorporate
the machinery
that they're familiar with.
They're building
business machines that
are punch card-run
with batch processing,
so they carry those technologies
into the mainframe computers
that they're building.
Now, look, you come
back after a week,
and you get handed a stack
of this weird green and white
paper with holes
punched in the side.
You probably don't have
any memory of this,
but I remember it deeply.
And you'd get handed
this stack of paper,
and then you'd go
back to your office
and you sit down and
start go through.
And then you realize
that, after page 39,
it's all gibberish, because
one of your punch cards
was out of order or upside-down,
or something like that.
So then you'd have to go
back and stand in line
with the high
priest or priestess,
and start the whole
process all over again.
That's really what it's like.
And the emphasis was on
bigger and bigger computers
able to handle more and more
large number batch processing.
So Licklider comes
along more than a decade
before personal computing and
30 years before the internet.
And the word computer
still has this kind
of ominous tone of a
intimidating device that's
kind of hidden away in
this over-lit, super air
conditioned, noisy,
fan-ridden space.
And it's about as far away
from this as we can imagine.
And this is really what that
team at DARPA, that Licklider
led, drives us to.
So we'll talk about
the film in a bit,
but a lot of the
leadership of that team
goes on to do amazing stuff.
So here's some
Licklider photographs.
This is DEC's PDP-8 that
was the first mini-computer,
an entire movement away
from mainframe computing
that really was key to
spawning the revolution.
So Licklider is playing
with this machine.
It came from Digital
Equipment Corporation,
which is an MIT spin-off,
Lincoln Labs spin-off.
And they're trying
to start to pursue
a more personalized
kind of computing
with these mini-computers.
On the lower left is the
team that does the internet.
And the only book
that Licklider wrote
is called libraries
of the future,
and he essentially envisions
digital storage of everything.
It's amazing work.
The librarians are
trying to wonder
what to do with computers,
and he essentially
gives them the entire picture.
So a very innovative character.
He grows up in St. Louis.
Both his parents are ministers,
and he's an only child.
Responsible kid,
but his parents let
him do things like assemble
automobiles in the living room.
For most of his life, he never
spent more than $50 on a car
because he would essentially
by junkers and parts
and put them together himself.
That's the way the
family drove around.
So he has a tremendous
facility for--
remember we talked
about mind in hand,
when we talked about the
Industrial Revolution.
Licklider has got that
tactile knowledge facility,
and it's part of why
he loves computers.
He falls in love with
psychology and becomes actually
quite a significant early
thinker about psychology,
when that whole field
is starting to change.
His World War II
experience is spent up
at Memorial Hall at
Harvard in the basement
with acoustics
researchers, studying
how pilots and the crew of
airplanes-- how they react
to this unbelievable
noise that they've
got in the pre-pressurized
cabins in World War II aircraft
with these huge propeller
engines next to their ears,
trying to hear radio signals.
And this is before there's
any kind of navigation system.
It's pre-LORAN.
It's obviously long before GPS.
So there's a terrible problem--
the communication systems
and the way in which
you navigate a lot--
typically, if you
can't see the stars.
So all kinds of plans
get lost over oceans
because the radio communications
don't get picked up.
So he's working on how can
we improve the man machine
interface around acoustics
in the cabin of airplanes?
So he's thinking a lot about
how people and machines work
together.
And that's what he contributes.
He's not a computer-- early
computer scientists really,
although he loves computing.
He plays with them all
the time, knows them
backwards and forwards.
He's bringing the ideas of
a psychologist to computing,
and that's what,
in many ways, makes
him a complete
breakthrough thinker.
He's able to take
ideas from psychology
and bring them into this early
computing field, not just
an engineering
perspective-- although he
has very good engineering
and physics capability.
And he writes an absolutely
seminal article in 1960
that essentially was still
working through his agenda
of what needs to happen.
It's an amazing vision.
He, for example, realizes
that 85% of human time
is spent getting
into a position to be
able to think about a problem--
arranging all the stuff,
pulling all the
material together,
and then you can think.
Suppose you could reduce that
85% by having the computer
do it for you, by having
the computer arrange
a lot of that stuff for you.
That's part of his concept.
The central concept
he has is the hope
is that human
brains and computing
machines will be coupled
together very tightly,
and that the resulting
partnership will
think as no human is
ever thought and process
data in a way not approached
by the information handling
machines we have today.
In other words,
he has this vision
of people and machines in this
collaborative relationship.
It's going to be a symbiotic
kind of relationship.
And let's think for
a minute about how
people thought about computing.
Now, we're all sitting around
wondering when the robots are
going to take our jobs.
That's the obsession
of the moment.
Licklider's coming
out of a time period
where there was a
similar obsession.
And Norbert Wiener-- who
pops up in this book,
and is another one of
MIT's absolute greats,
a brilliant mathematician--
Wiener is the one who
invents the term cybernetics.
And Wiener has this
vision saying, look out--
and he writes in the late '40s--
the computers are
coming, and they're
going to be smarter than we are.
It's a very dark picture of
what computing is going to be.
And you all seen
2001-- the Hal computer
in 2001, Space Odyssey?
AUDIENCE: I know of it.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
You know of it.
Well, shows my age.
But that's the kind of vision,
this dark vision of computers
taking over our lives.
And that was alive and
well as early computing
started to take off.
And actually one of
the conceptualizers
who got people worrying about
computing was Norbert Wiener.
But along comes Licklider with
his background in psychology,
and he has a completely
different vision.
And his vision
wins, thank heavens.
So he understands that
things like human perception,
and goal-setting, and judgment,
and insight, and intuition--
machines can't do
that, that these are
incredible human attributes.
And the machine's
just not can be
able to equal us on that stuff,
that certain kind of feel
we have about how things fall
together and shape up in place.
So those qualities are
going to surpass machines,
but then machines are going
to be able to do stuff
that we can't do, that we're
not particularly good at,
and don't want to
spend a lot of time on.
So there's going to
be a relationship.
So Licklider is spending a
lot of time at Lincoln Lab,
playing on computers
up at Lincoln Lab.
He starts to master all
those early machines,
including the DEC PDP-8,
the first mini-computer--
real mini-computer.
He leads the MIT
Psychology Department,
and joins BBN, which is the
premier acoustics consulting
firm.
And they do things like
design the acoustics
for Lincoln Center, the
famous acoustics firm.
And they had this
idea, gee, maybe
we ought to get in the
computing business.
Maybe these computers are
actually here to stay.
So Licklider is hired
at BBN to bring them
into the early computing age.
And that's what he does.
In this 1960 article,
his key image
is a fig tree
pollinated by a wasp--
in other words, the relationship
between the fig tree
and the wasp is
complete symbiotic,
they're mutually supporting.
And that's the
vision that he has
of what computing
is going to be.
So it's this partnership
between computers and people
with a complementary
set of functions.
And the partnership
has to be in real time.
We have to get rid of all
this batch processing stuff.
That has to go.
It's got to be real time.
The computer is
to relieve people
of that drudgery factor,
the 85% of the set up time
we spend getting ready to think.
It is a time of what is being
talked about as time-sharing.
These big massive mainframes
behind glass with the priests
and priestesses dressed
in white lab coats,
people don't get access to them.
It's like going to
the Oracle of Delphi.
You just can't get in there.
And he has a vision of
could we, in effect,
take that computer back
from the Oracle of Delphi
and get people on this thing.
And how are we going to
do that with mainframes?
We're going to do it through
what's called, at the time,
time-sharing.
Let people have access
to a share of time.
And he has a vision of
central computers, and then--
as a competing center
with interconnected users
tying into that central
computing system.
He understands
things like building
a network of people
aided by computers
that become in effect a
network of thinking centers.
And that network concept
really is a core idea
that is what his team at
DARPA later establishes
BBN as the internet.
He understands that
artificial intelligence
isn't an analogous way of
thinking about thinking--
that it can help us understand
intellectual processes.
He has a vision of a computer
being a desk console, not
a mainframe--
in other words,
radically smaller
than even the
mini-computer that he's
starting to play with from DEC.
He just has a series of these
concepts in this 1960 article
that lays out what's
going to be happening.
He envisions
interactive computing.
He envisions programming
is not just programming.
He starts to understand
that this is a science--
in a way, a linguistic
kind of science in itself,
and is deserving full respect--
that computer science is a true
science like other sciences,
that it's not just
a new tool set.
It's something organized
around one of the fundamentals.
Information is one
of the fundamentals,
one of the foundational
building blocks of the universe.
And you're organizing a whole
field around information.
Computing is going
to be a science,
and he recognizes that
very, very early on,
long before others.
It'll have practical
applications,
but it's worthy of a whole
intellectual field on its own.
And he sees how
closely tied computing
can be to cognitive science.
So he has a whole vision of
what he calls dynamic modeling.
In other words,
this is an era where
you get statistics on paper.
But he has the vision that, if
you put them on your computer,
you can start to play
with each element
and begin to turn them
into graphs and designs,
and get a much more realistic
feel for how the data is
related, and start to play
with the different variables.
And you're going to be able
to feed hundreds and thousands
of variables into
your computer in a way
that you can never
even think of,
when people are doing
statistics by pencil and paper.
So he has a whole vision
of this whole-- what
he calls dynamic
modeling, the modeling
role that computing effect plays
in a very dramatic way now.
It's that computing can handle
this problem of complexity
because of its
relentless ability
to deal with thousands and
now millions of variables.
So economics is
a profession that
was organized around
essentially you couldn't really
handle much more than
three, four, five variables
operating at the same time.
Computing would
enable science to cope
with a profound issue
like climate change,
and actually start to
be able to model that.
So he understands
all this stuff,
and he starts to lay this out
piece after piece after piece
for people to think about.
I mentioned earlier
the electronic library.
He understands that
all information
is going to be online
and stored online,
and is going to be accessible
to everybody who can
get onto one of these things.
And it will be
the library and it
will be the reference
librarian for you.
In other words, it's going
to be able to organize
your information in ways
that could never have
been previously anticipated.
15 years before the PC and
30 years before the internet,
he's seeing graphics,
computing graphics, computer
rich personal workstations,
human computer symbiosis,
interactive computing,
networks, the idea
of an online community,
a thinking community,
online libraries, instant
retrieval, data organization,
computing language,
programming that's
elevated from a tool
set to a true science--
a whole digital
medium of expression.
So he is a visionary.
He has this vision.
He starts writing about
the intergalactic network.
It's the worldwide web decades
before Tim Berners-Lee here
pulls it off.
He's a visionary, and
of a remarkable degree.
And there's no vision
champion at the time,
but then DARPA
hires him out of BBN
to lead essentially
this whole development
of personal computing.
So it's a completely rare
moment where a visionary becomes
the vision enabler.
What happens here?
So 1957 is the Shock of Sputnik.
So DARPA gets created.
DARPA's originally given
the space mission, because.
Eisenhower's angry
at the services
because they weren't
talking to each other,
and Russians got the
first satellite up.
And it wasn't about a
nice blinking thing,
it was about first strike
ballistic missile capability.
It was very serious.
But then he took space
away and gave it to NASA,
so DARPA had to start
thinking of things to do.
And they come up with a
lot of creative stuff,
but the big early DARPA
set of accomplishments
is really Licklider
and his team.
And so Jack Kennedy
and Secretary
of Defense Robert McNamara
go through the Cuban Missile
Crisis, which is a
complete nightmare.
And we do things like get
within 20 minutes of launching
a first strike by mistake.
And they realize that
they've got something
that they call a really serious
command and control problem.
And Jack Ruina, who's head
of DARPA, who's another MIT
faculty member, hires
Licklider to come in and deal
with the command
and control problem.
And Licklider's response to
Jack Ruina is, wait a minute,
I'm working on computing and
making computing personal.
What do I know about the
command and control problem?
But they have a
conversation, and Ruina
starts to see that what
Licklider is working on
is exactly what he is concerned
about the command and control
problem.
With all these capabilities that
Licklider is thinking about,
they need to tackle this
command and control problem.
So Licklider comes to
DARPA, and because he's
working on what DARPA
calls a presidential--
in other words, this is the
problem the president himself--
President Kennedy
himself has posed--
fix the command and
control problem.
He has resources.
So it's a very powerful moment.
Ruina hadn't really
thought about the linkage
between behavior and
computing and the kind of way
that Licklider has
really thought through,
but begins to see what
the possibilities are.
So this is really when
DARPA becomes DARPA.
Some of the culture of DARPA--
we've talked a bit about they--
I'll just summarize
some of the rules sets--
hire great program managers
that are world-class,
give them an enormous
amount of power.
They have the
authority at DARPA.
Unleash them.
Let them develop a
vision, and then find
the best people in
the country to do it,
and they're on the problem.
That is not the way
R&D organizations are
organized in the United States.
That's not the way we do it.
We have NSF.
It has a program manager.
The program manager is overseen
by a peer review system.
They wait for applications to
come in from the scientists
saying what they'd like to do.
They review the applications.
The peer review team makes a
decision on who gets funded.
The project manager
is essentially
doing the arranging
here, but peer review
makes the core decision.
It's a much more
bureaucratic process,
and it's a bottom-up system.
Look, there's a lot of
strengths in that system.
I don't want to
knock that system.
It's an important function
to have for science
so that scientists themselves
can originate ideas.
That's not what DARPA does.
DARPA has strong
program managers.
They develop the ideas, and they
go out and make them happen.
And program managers don't
last much more than four years
at DARPA--
three to five years--
so they've got
that period of time
to get done with their project.
They've got to get something
happening within a relatively
short period of time.
So that's going to affect
what they try to do.
They're not working on
25-year projects at DARPA.
They're working on stuff that
can be stood up in a relatively
short period of time.
And it's just a very
different organizational model
for a science organization--
no peer review, two sign offs.
If you're a program manager, you
figure out what you want to do,
what direction
you want to go to.
You sell that to your office
director and to the director,
and that's it.
And it could be funded that day.
Can move very, very fast.
So they're organized around this
whole grand challenge concept.
DARPA doesn't want to
do incremental advance.
It only wants to do technology
revolutionary breakthroughs
that will change everything.
So it doesn't want to waste--
let other people do
the incremental stuff.
That's not DARPA's job.
And it's a right
left model, so it
wants to look at what's
going to come out
of the pipeline, what the
technology is that it wants--
personal computing-- and then
go back into the pipeline
and figure out the research
that's going to get this
outcome, again, within the
life of the program manager--
in this, say, four
or five-year period.
So it's just it's
really different.
Licklider pulls together
different teams.
So the other thing
about DARPA is
that essentially the role
of the program manager
is to find great groups
and to support them.
And that's what Licklider does.
So DARPA's different
because it's
working as an institutional
entity in the R&D space.
It's another
institutional R&D entity,
but it is also organized around
personal face-to-face great
group creation.
So it takes the two
sides of the equation
that we treated as two
entirely different classes--
it is putting them together.
That's why DARPA follows
after our discussion
in the great group class.
That's who Licklider is finding.
He's finding these
amazing, great groups.
And we've seen some
of them before.
These are all who's who of the
history of computer science.
We talked about Doug Engelbart.
There he is.
He's someone that Lick
finds and supports,
even though the Stanford
Research Institute
doesn't know what he's doing.
They don't know what
he's doing there.
He does this you know
unbelievable demonstration
with all this
breakthrough material.
At MIT, project MAC is right
there at Technology Square.
You can kind of recognize that
building on the lower left.
So after Licklider leaves DARPA,
he goes to join Project MAC.
But meanwhile, he gets stood
up by Ferdinand Corbato and Bob
Fano.
The history of what comes out
of that place-- and it's all
DARPA-funded-- is
just breathtaking.
So when you go buy that
building at Technology Square--
I think it's 500
Technology Square--
take off your hat,
because amazing stuff.
Absolutely amazing
stuff occurred there.
Within MIT, there's this
fascinating conflict.
There are two competing
visions of computer science
fighting for the
same DARPA money.
So Marvin Minsky,
great roboticist--
great, one of the all-time
greats-- just died recently.
Amazing figure.
Minsky had this vision that
computer thinking would be
superior to people's thinking.
So he has the Artificial
Intelligence Laboratory
and he's running
that vision, and then
Licklider and
Corbato and Fano are
running the computer
is our friend,
it's going to be a
symbiotic relationship,
we're going to do
personal computing--
very different ideas battling
each other for funding.
It took years of negotiation
to put together CSAIL
because you had these two
different visions that
competed with each other.
Just like we talked about the
competition over the genome
last week in the
great groups session,
this was one of those
great competitions.
Each side is pushing each other.
And Minsky and team would do
unbelievable robotics stuff
and they would say, top this.
And the MAC team would come
back with the responses.
So it was a wonderful
competition going on here.
But creating CSAIL required two
co-directors at the outset--
somebody from computer
science and somebody
from artificial intelligence.
It's kind of settled down.
They're all on the
same project now.
But that was a 20-year or
longer project to get there.
So it's a remarkable
set of communities,
including project MAC at MIT,
but that's just one of them
that gets created.
So all the early computer
science departments
are funded by DARPA.
DARPA really creates them.
That's why there is
computer science that's
so deep and rich in
the United States.
Licklider's three research
priorities at DARPA are
time-sharing-- which is
really interactive computing,
and that's like
personal computing--
and then graphics and modeling--
and another great
name, Ivan Sullivan
ran that piece, and that's
early computing graphics--
and then networking.
And Bob Taylor, who we
talked about last week,
who goes to Xerox PARC, comes
out of DARPA to do that.
And that's where
he gets his stuff.
And he and Larry
Roberts, as well,
are the ones that lead the
effort to stand up computing.
And Luyao told us
about him last week.
We sent around his obit, because
he just died this past week.
It's a wonderful obit--
if you all get a
chance to read it--
that appeared in New York Times.
The ARPANET gets created.
So Licklider creates
this thing at DARPA.
He has two different
stints at DARPA.
He's there for several
years in each stint.
But he creates a community that
keeps carrying on the projects.
In other words, they agree
on what the agenda is,
and they keep working
down the list together.
So DARPA doesn't-- isn't
always able to do this.
Often there's a real problem--
when a program manager
leaves after their three
to five-year stint, what
happens to their work?
Who does the follow one?
But Licklider builds
this community
that keeps the project going for
way over a decade and a half.
And Taylor and Larry
Roberts, out of Lincoln Lab,
really lead the effort
to do the internet.
They hire BBN, Licklider's old
firm, to actually carry it out.
And that's done right
here in Cambridge.
So the internet gets
done just up the road.
I won't go into the whole
story about it, but it's--
two great things occur in 1969--
we go to the Moon and
we do the internet.
And in 1969, nobody had
ever heard of the internet.
But in the end, which
is the more significant?
And that's going on
just up the street here.
It's a pretty
breathtaking moment.
These are some of the figures.
This is Vint Cerf and
Bob Kahn, who were--
lead the whole protocol effort--
TCPIP, the whole
internet protocol system
that's really at the heart
of the internet system.
Larry Roberts, who came
out of Lincoln Lab,
persuades the DARPA
director to use email.
So DARPA's like an
early email user.
So everybody in
DARPA goes on email.
They nurture this thing along.
They're one of the
early user bases.
It becomes this system
of communication,
because DARPA's using it for
the entire ARPANET community.
It's originally stood up with
about five universities linked.
The real problem they've
got is that, because DARPA's
trying to stand up these early
computer science departments,
and lots of breakthroughs
are happening in computing,
DARPA's having to
spend a fortune buying
new computers for each one
of its university research
centers.
And it's costing them a fortune.
They're spending their
money on the next generation
of computer advance.
And one of the reasons they
have to do the internet
is that, gee, if they only
had to buy one computer
and everybody
could get on it, it
would be a gigantic
money saver, and they'd
be able to do much more stuff.
So they have this
internal reason.
Now, the external
reason for the internet
is much more complicated.
One of the reasons
is that it's going
to be a secure communications
system at the time
of terrible threats.
Now, you all are--
probably don't have
much recollection
of 9/11, but sure
enough, the only way
we knew about each other on 9/11
was because the internet still
worked.
The phone system in New York
City went down in a flash.
And it worked.
It turned out to be an
enormously important
fallback communications system,
because it is so resilient.
In other word, you can establish
those network lines essentially
through any connection, not
just a straight one-to-one
connection like
the phone system.
So that was part of the
rationale for developing
the internet, but
frankly, Licklider
had a vision of what the
internet was going to be,
which is really why they did it.
And then they had this excuse of
trying to reduce their computer
budget for buying
fancy computers for all
their computer science
departments around the country
at universities.
So it's an amazing story.
We heard the story
from Luyao last week
about how personal
computing comes about.
A lot of that
community is being--
came right out of Licklider's
support of university research
groups, and then moves over
to carry it out at Xerox PARC.
And then, of course, Xerox
PARC is unable to do it,
as you explained.
But luckily, Steve
Jobs buys the rights
to walk through
and see the stuff.
And he's a great implementer.
All right.
Steph, what did I miss?
STEPH: The one
point that I really
emphasize to set up the
questions is something
that Bill touched on,
which is that there
was a very significant
dispute between the scientists
and engineers who were trying
to create the integrated
system versus the
isolated, siloed systems.
And that ends up playing
a big role in, I think,
how many of you perceived
the readings and the kinds
of questions that you asked.
I think the place where I'd
like to start our conversation
is about the mechanisms by which
the computing revolution was
created.
We have a question from
Beth, and she poses,
how much of a
technological revolution
is the scientific
breakthrough versus the vision
of how to use it?
So I think that really
gets at the heart of
whether or not a technology can
be disruptive or revolutionary
versus whether the
implementation is
what actually matters, as you
just noted with Steve Jobs.
AUDIENCE: Just to clarify,
when you vision, do you
mean JCR's vision, or do you
mean the visionary who comes
after, which is Steve Jobs?
Which vision are
you talking about?
STEPH: Well, I think
we'll let Beth clarify.
BETH: I think it is kind
of a cumulative process.
The reason that Steve Jobs
was able to have a vision
was because JCR had his vision.
So it's kind of like at each
step in the road, the reason
we were able to progress,
was it because of the vision,
or was it because of
technology, or was it
this guy was at the right
place at the right time?
How else could things
have progressed,
if it had been under
different circumstance?
STEPH: So how much
weight, I guess,
are we giving the invention,
the mechanism by which this
was achieved on its own?
AUDIENCE: Well, I think a good
way to think about it is--
you know ancient dynasties?
There's one that was--
took a while and
didn't do anything
that was that significant.
But they built up
the infrastructure
so that a dynasty
comes in right after,
and they end up doing all these
awesome things, and everyone
talks about that one.
So I think it's kind
of like Steve Jobs,
Bill Gates have a voice because,
again, billionaires-- everyone
is like, oh.
There's a saying where, I
wish I was rich so then people
would listen to me.
So people pay attention
because they became wealthy.
And they kind of popularized
the idea of the engineer,
and they gave a lot of
respect to the engineer,
because now they make money.
But in the past, like in the
'70s, there's a couple series
and a couple of biographies
where there's really,
really brilliant
people that might be--
I would even say more brilliant
than some people today--
in those technologies.
But they just weren't valued
economically or socially.
In the '70s, being a
nerd was being a nerd.
Nowadays, being a
nerd is like, damn,
he might be a billionaire--
I'm going to be nice to him.
Now it's cool to be
a nerd-- to be smart.
STEPH: I think we'll hit
that point again in a second,
so keep that thought process.
RASHEED: I think Steve and Bill
Gates had a vision socially
like, we're going to
make being a nerd cool
again because we can't make
a whole bunch of money.
You think they had
that vision when
they were being nerds
and making money,
that we're going to make--
basically being a nerd
cool because [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: What I'm saying
is-- so it's the difference
between--
like somebody gets a car--
somebody has a Rolls Royce
and somebody has a Toyota.
This first wave--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Licklider
would have a junker.
AUDIENCE: Hm?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Licklider
would have a junker--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: --that
he personally would build.
AUDIENCE: Well, what
I'm trying to say
is that it's an
item that doesn't
touch the hands of
a lot of people,
so it's not valued, versus--
the personal computer
was a big thing
because everyone
could interact with it
and would be able to
communicate with it.
These big computers,
it was only if you
were in the institution, if you
were probably a grad student
or more brilliant--
that you've got
to interact with the computer.
And what they
really did was just
make it common for
everybody to use.
Really that's what the
entrepreneur-- the Gates,
Ford--
is somebody who takes a
complicated technology
and simplifies it
to the point where
[INAUDIBLE] a large
subset of consumers,
if not all consumers.
Any other questions?
STEPH: Sorry, I'm
comfortable with silence,
so I like it when people think.
AUDIENCE: What was
interesting about this
though, that I
connected, is when you
think about startups or any--
I guess vision organization,
it always starts--
Reid Hoffman talks
about this, which is you
want to have a key
insight about society.
So not all people know
this, but Mark Zuckerberg
was a psychology major.
He just happened to take
computer science classes,
and then would say that he
studied computer science
because it was easier when
he got into the marketplace
and he had to get investors.
JCR was psychology, so
he had a main insight
into how the human
brain worked, and also
a secret about human nature--
that it seemed that he used
that to his advantage in order
to create computer
systems, which I thought
was really, really interesting.
RASHEED: Yeah, I think I'm going
to echo Martin's point here.
I think a lot of this
kind of visionary insight
was built off of a lot
of things that he did.
So he had all this
tactile knowledge,
skill to build cars and things
like that, but as you can see,
probably used that
psychology background
a lot more when he was trying
to figure out how are we
going to put together
and really move
personal computing forward.
And I think another
understated point here was,
in this great groups
model, I think he
and Licklider definitely
not only underscores,
but kind of creates that
great groups model for DARPA.
But not only
bringing it together
and finding these people, but--
I think you mentioned like
a lot of these projects
weren't on the normal
three to five years.
But he took maybe four or
five different collaborators
and said, we're
going to build out
10 years, 15 years,
and then just
stay working on
the same projects
and solve all these
five different problems
so he could move the
whole field forward,
instead of just focusing
on one or two problems.
In this great groups
model, he creates
great groups within DARPA, and
then that leadership, as well,
and moves that forward.
And so he's obviously using his
psychology insight and research
maybe a little bit more
than his computing aptitude.
AUDIENCE: I think
[INAUDIBLE] I remember
in the reading we talked about
the cool think about being
an entrepreneur in
DARPA is that you
get to be an entrepreneur
in multiple things at once.
So if you're an entrepreneur,
you only have your business
and you can only
really focus on that.
But an entrepreneur in
DARPA who leads a vision,
gets to touch multiple
products at once-- you
can see that with JCR, where
do you have the three sections.
But what I find is interesting
is why isn't he more famous?
Because this is the first
time I heard of him, honestly.
He probably should
get more credit
than a jobs or Bill Gates.
And even in the papers about
Bill Gates, he was like, well,
yeah, we really did this
revolution in the '70s.
And it's like, you
did the last 2%.
So it was pretty interesting.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: He is an
absolutely remarkable figure.
And the core was this vision
that he had, and that--
and this image of a crossover.
Often, great technologies
are crossover technologies.
When Jobs creates the iPod,
he's taking an MP3 player
of high quality and
certain new attributes,
but he's joining with
something entirely different--
a remarkable way of
organizing the music industry.
And it's two pieces that
get joined together,
and that's at the
heart, I think,
of what Licklider is able to do.
He's able to take his
capability at computing
and his engineering and
computing capabilities,
but he crosses it with
his whole background
and set of understandings that
he comes to with psychology.
And it's that crossover
that makes him
an absolutely unique figure.
So when you all are thinking
about how to do great stuff,
just keep that crossover idea.
Bringing something from
here and moving it over here
is really at the heart
of a tremendous amount
of creativity.
It may be the definition
It's what he pulls off.
By the time Licklider
finishes his second stint--
which he's not as happy at
DARPA the second time around.
He has a director that
doesn't get along with as well
as he did with Jack Ruina and
another famous DARPA director,
named Heilmeier--
Heilmeier, excuse me.
That team of has worked
their way through those three
critical projects.
They've done the
internet by '69.
They've done desktop
computing, carried out
with some DARPA support by
largely ex-DARPA funded folks
at Xerox PARC.
And then they've done computer
graphics, and a lot of that
moves over to Xerox PARC,
as well, and then from there
to Apple.
But they've worked their
way through those pieces.
Let me just mention
the film here briefly.
Rasheed, you can-- we'll
get to this in a second,
although we'll let Steph
do a couple more questions.
The film was this
desperate attempt
by these people who have
created the internet.
And you saw them.
This is an amazing collection.
A lot of on the film.
Larry Roberts is there;
and Frank Hart, who
led the BBN team; and Bob
Kahn, who's on the BBN team,
then goes to DARPA and works
with Vint Cerf on the TCPIP
internet protocol system;
and Paul Baran who
has a vision for what--
how to put together
the whole packet switching
system to begin with,
that's at the core
of the internet.
All these famous
internet pioneers
are all put together on the
film, and they're desperate.
They are desperate because
the internet has only
gone to about 50 different
university computer science
departments.
And they realize that they've
got this earth-shattering
communication system, and
they're trying to explain
desperately to--
on a 16-millimeter film
what they've accomplished.
I think it's '72
they do the film.
It's not until really 1993, 1994
that the internet completely
scales up.
So it's a long hiatus.
And NSF actually plays a
very, very important role
in the scale up, because it gets
turned over by DARPA and NSF--
and NSF under Erich Bloch, who
is the only NSF director who
came out of industry.
So Erich Bloch was one of the
leaders of the IBM 360 project
and was a winner
of the president's
Medal of Technology, but
he was an IBM officially.
Wasn't a scientist.
So he gets leadership
of NSF, and he
creates NSF's very strong
computing organization,
pulls one of the leaders
of deck to run it.
And they treat computing
as a full science.
That's another moment
in Licklider's vision
is when NSF starts
to treat computer
science as a true
science, not just
a nice tool for other
scientists to play with.
So that's a pretty
critical moment too.
And Erich Bloch and some
others understand the power
of the internet
as a communication
system in science, and then
they spread it to universities
all over the place.
That creates a fabulous early
audience, and then it scales.
So that's kind of
what plays out there.
But it's a remarkable--
another remarkable is
part of the story here.
Steph, let's go to a
question or two more.
STEPH: Great.
I have precisely
two more questions,
the first is with
a sentiment that
was shared in the last couple
of pages in the reading.
And I'll read a quote now.
It says, "Technology
isn't destiny,
no matter how inexorable
its evolution may seem.
The way its
capabilities are used
is much a matter of cultural
choice and historical accident
as it's politics or fashion."
And I think back to maybe the
first or the second course
where we began to reflect
about the role of culture
and technology transfer
and technology adoption,
and in thinking about the sort
of functionalist ethics that we
might have-- this
is by Amartya Sen--
he's a very famous economists
who came out of India
in developmental economics--
and thinking about the ways in
which we're evaluating vision.
And it seems-- and I have a
couple of notes here from which
I will read--
that many of the people
who we have truly
regarded as innovators and
as transformative members
of society have
created things that
are effectively public goods.
They've really approached
technology and engineering
from a utility ethics
framework-- not so
much about having that
bias to commercialization,
like maybe Steve
Jobs did, but it
was the Lickliders and the
Edisons who really thought
about how they could
create a product that
was going to transform
society for everyone.
It wasn't going to be a product
that was going to be accessible
only to the few.
And so in thinking about our
ethics of commercialization
today, perhaps I
thought it would
be worth it to become a little
philosophical, in the sense
that Licklider was very
philosophical about the role
that technology played in
the development of society--
and ask ourselves about the ways
in which our commercialization
bias may be precluding
us from creating
the so-called
disruptive inventions
that we still wish to pursue.
RASHEED: So I think
this is a cool question
because you get to do both--
bring in, just like you said,
a lot of the cultural aspects
that might be overlooked when
you have this commercialization
bias.
But I'm not sure--
or in this context, I think
Licklider's got a head up
because the field is wide open.
And so nobody's really thought
about personal computing
before, so he gets to
really define the field
and make it general enough
so that it can be applicable
everywhere.
But in every sense, you get
the idea that-- time-sharing
and all these
things-- he's trying
to make computing a
lot more accessible.
And so I think that's a really
cool and seminal thought
to make things more
accessible, and that'll
give you the innovative,
transformative, and really
disruptive ideals-- to bring
this technology from one
and spread it around.
And so the spreading
effect, I'm not
sure how to quantify
it like Licklider
did, but I'm interested in what
projects that DARPA might be
running now or
might be looking at,
to see if there's still those
people within the organization
that are looking at bringing
technologies that might exist
now that might just be
[INAUDIBLE] or high risk,
and spreading that to
a more normative phase,
maybe like Licklider did.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: It's an
interesting point, Steph,
that you raise, and Rasheed,
that you comment on,
because there's a very strong
culture in computing, including
a very strong culture
in MIT computing,
that computing should
be free, and computing
should be in the commons, and
computing should serve us all.
And that's actually a very
strong ethos that, in a way--
and I think it's your point--
comes out of the way
in which Licklider
and that remarkable team
evolved this technology.
Because this is not a
for-profit operation.
They are essentially
trying to spring
a transformative
technology onto the world
by building it in the
commons, and creating it
into the commons, and making
it universally accessible.
That's a remarkable project.
That's not normally
the way we do
stuff in a capitalist country.
You've identified an
interesting kind of strand
here that's a different kind of
technology development story.
And it's a different story
than the Edison story.
It enables, Martin,
as you point out,
Gates and Jobs to
get extremely rich.
But all the
foundational stuff was
thrown into the commons
long ahead of them,
which was an enabler
for them, as well.
So interesting.
Thanks for bringing
the philosophy in.
STEPH: [INAUDIBLE] for
what it's worth, I find--
or I personally
think that doing good
is not exclusive
mutually with doing well
for yourself and
for other people.
I think that there's
a lot of value
in thinking about
the ways in which you
can reach a wide audience
and transform society, and at
the same time, do
well for yourself,
and then return that
value onto society.
But to what extent?
The kinds of people
who are capitalizing
on the gains of
the Lickliders is--
I'm not sure that they may all
share my vision for the world.
AUDIENCE: I'll add
a point to that.
I think a lot of it matters-- it
matters how you define success.
What channel's creating wealth?
Because you'd say, yeah,
these innovators didn't become
wealthy, or the US
did become wealthy,
Bill Gates and Steve Jobs became
wealthy, and their employees.
But at the same time, how much
the net worth was increased
in the US based on the economic
output, based on these people,
and also their legacy?
Because most likely in the
future, we'll re-look into this
and say, actually,
these were the pioneers.
And they get even more traction.
Bob Metcalfe, who
made the internet,
made the original one.
And then other people
implemented it and made
it better and better and
better, so he's like, oh,
it's awesome,
because I get credit
for all these brilliant
things people did after me.
So I wouldn't have been
able to do any of this,
but I get all this credit.
And I think that another
sector that I could compare to,
which is space.
So NASA went very fast and used
a lot of resources in order
to go into space, and they
really set the framework.
I listened to an
astronaut talk about it,
and he'd said, our job
is to widen the horizons,
because it's going to be a
while until it's commercially
viable for other people to do.
But that's our job, to
really go into the places
where a capitalist can't go.
But there is a net positive
on our society because of it.
And that's kind of
the job of government,
to do the stuff that
individuals can't
do for the net positive
of the society.
So I think there is a lot of--
there is a wealth
creation there.
They create a
wealth of knowledge.
They get respected and
honored much higher maybe.
So I think it really
depends how you define it.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: How about
a closing thought, Steph?
STEPH: Yeah, that sets us
up for the closing thought,
which is really about
Licklider's legacy.
I really appreciated
that Bill had
us read the component in
which the author is having
his wife Linda reflect on Lick
and the ways in which he passed
away, and the reaction from
the computing community about
not only his legacy, but the
ways in which he had been
such an incredible
not only mentor,
but champion-- which was
a word that you used today
maybe for the first time.
The kinds of mentors that
one can have-- there's
the people who will
help you learn things,
and then there's the people
who will advocate for you.
And Lick was really the
champion of computing,
not only for so many people,
but for the field itself,
with ARPA being his champion.
And I think there's a lot to be
said for finding those mentors,
and I hope that we in this
room have found those mentors
in our own lives, or on the
path to finding those people,
and that MIT and
our institutions
generally help to connect
us with the people who
will help us make
the revolutions
that we want to see happen.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Great, thank you.
Rasheed, a couple of
thoughts about the film clip?
RASHEED: Yeah.
So I think the film clip is
really a little bit weird
to watch, because it was really
putting a face, and a name,
and a voice to all these
people that we just read about.
And they came out about as I
expected, especially because I
think the audience of
the film was really
trying to make
the internet ideas
and computing a
lot more palatable
for the general audience.
And so it was nice to
see them kind of struggle
with translating what
they do on the daily basis
in their research, which
is highly technical,
to general population.
And I think it's why
be needed time to ask,
are these sort of efforts
that DARPA should be doing
normally-- to take these
high, very technical,
research-based--
you might need a
PhD to understand
what's going on on a project.
And then really translating
it for that public good
of disseminating
scientific information.
AUDIENCE: So to
rephrase the question,
you're asking basically
should DARPA be engaging in
high risk, high rewards?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Little bit louder.
AUDIENCE: I'm trying
to figure out--
so I was thinking, is the
question basically that,
should DARPA be engaging in
relatively technical projects
that might have really
huge impacts to society?
RASHEED: I think more
so, should DARPA,
with each project that
they take on-- should they
be advocating to the general
public as much as possible?
STEPH: Should there be a
communication component--
AUDIENCE: OK.
STEPH: --to the
research that they do,
much like they'll be doing
this weekend at the Science
March or the Climate
March next weekend.
AUDIENCE: Is DARPA
going to be there?
STEPH: I don't know.
Will they?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: It's an
interesting point about DARPA,
because in the IT
revolution, DARPA
is working to stand up
that revolution essentially
in the civilian economy, not
in a closed-system defense
economy.
And there were
conscious decisions
that DARPA made there.
So the military is often
pretty good at getting
that first prototype out, the
initial breakthrough prototype.
What it doesn't really
have the resources to do
are the relentless series of
follow-on incremental advances.
And clearly, the IT revolution
that we've been living through
for the last 25 years
is predominantly
incremental advances,
some of which
can be obviously
quite significant.
But the basic framework
was kind of in place
more than 20 years ago, and
we'd been in effect building
on that.
And DARPA understood that
the military would never
have the resources--
that it can really
use this personal
computing system
and the internet system--
they would be incredible tools
to create a whole new
organizational set
of mechanisms for the military.
But it was going to stand it
up in the civilian sector,
and then the military
could buy it back
from the civilian sector
after the civilian sector
did all the incremental
work and flooded
the sector with investment.
So for a long period
of time, the military
was the principal spender on
computing and on software.
It dominated as the big
buyer in that sector
for actually a fairly
significant period of time.
That era is long gone.
The military's control
of these sectors
is infinitesimally small now,
because they've been stood up,
and the military buys them back.
So that's a different kind
of way for DARPA to operate.
In the next piece we're
going to do in a second,
we're going to talk
about DARPA developing
technologies within
the military and how
it operated in that way,
which is, in some ways,
quite challenging.
Closing thought on the film?
Question?
AUDIENCE: Just very short--
I do think there is stuff for
DARPA to do, at the very least,
in today's society.
I worked on a
DARPA-funded project.
People I generally
talked to-- oh yeah,
DARPA is just a money sinkhole.
They just have a ton of money.
A lot of people
don't necessarily
see how a defense agency's
research comes down
to benefit them.
RASHEED: So as a
closing thought,
I think DARPA has the
advantage where they can
do this high risk, high reward.
Under the guise of defense,
I think they kind of get away
with not being able to say--
or being able to be
like, it's classified,
or we don't really have to tell
you under defense parameters
or protocols, or
the reasons why we
want to look into
these projects can
be a little more complicated.
But I do see--
and in cases like this,
where to have ARPANET,
which obviously has
great potential,
if you do that type
transfer and move it
into the civilian
sector, and then you
get this IT revolution
that follows on after.
s so I think it's
important for DARPA
to keep initiatives like this
for maybe bigger projects that
are a lot easier to stand
up in civilian sectors.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah,
an important point, Rasheed.
DARPA gets a lot of
slack because it's
under that national
security mission banner.
So it's able to take the
kind of risks and aim
for a set of
breakthroughs that's
harder for a civilian
agency to undertake.
This is wild stuff.
Think about coming up with
this stuff in the 1960s.
It's pretty amazing.
And that national security
justification was pretty key.
All right, so now
we're going to look
at a different side of DARPA.
This is a chapter
from our textbook.
And there's a couple
of topics here.
DARPA's a very unique
institutional model
that operates at both the
personal and institutional
levels, as we talked about.
And then secondly, DARPA's
organizational rule set.
DARPA also creates lots of
the foundational technologies
behind what is called the
revolution in military affairs.
So here's the setting.
Harold Brown And Bill Perry are
running Jimmy Carter's Defense
Department.
So Harold Brown's
Secretary of Defense.
He's president of Caltech.
And Perry is out of Stanford.
They are great technologists.
Imagine the top leadership
of the Defense Department
and the hands of really
hot-shot technologists.
Doesn't usually happen.
And they've got a big
problem on their hands.
The problem is the American
army, in particular,
has been completely
demoralized by the Vietnam War,
and has largely disintegrated.
It is not, in many ways,
a truly functioning force.
And the Cold War is
heating up, and there's
a monster presence of
Soviet and Allied armies
in Eastern Europe.
And the problem that
Brown and Perry have got
is that, because the US Army
is weak and perceived as weak,
there's kind of nothing in the
way of that Soviet army having
the capability of moving
right into Western Europe.
And that's not a good
situation because then you
have to decide whether to use
nuclear weapons very quickly.
You don't have a lot of time.
You've got to decide
whether you use
nuclear weapons,
which essentially
means ending the world.
It's not the kind of decision
you want to have to make.
So Perry and Brown started
thinking about what
they call an offset strategy.
Can we start to
restore the strength
of the American military?
They're not going to do it
with a mass army, and a citizen
army, and building
thousands of tanks,
and adding millions
to the military.
That's unaffordable
and they're just not--
it's not going to happen.
And they'd be
putting those people
into a broken
institution anyway.
So the Army's in the
process of restoring itself
through leadership of
people like Colin Powell,
and a whole generation
of new army leaders
that really restore
that operation
in a remarkable kind of way.
It restores itself.
But that is an underway
project at that time.
And what Perry and Brown
start is a whole set
of thinking about can we get
a significant on-the-ground
conventional warfare superiority
so that the Soviet Union won't
even think about coming
through the Fulda Gap
and moving on Western Europe.
And that's what they embark on,
and that becomes DARPA's job.
So DARPA develops precision
strike, they develop stealth,
and they develop UAVs
or drones as core.
And then they're also doing a
lot of stuff with submarines
that nobody ever talks about.
So I don't know what that is.
Something's going on there with
submarines, undersea warfare.
But we know about
the other three.
We have a pretty good
idea what those look like.
And these are not technologies
that the services want.
The Air Force is
dominated by pilots.
They don't want drones.
That's like the last
thing they want.
The Air Force wants airplanes
that can actually fly.
They don't want
these stealth things
that, if the computers
weren't continually adjusting
the exact movement
of the aircraft,
it would fall like a rock.
It's completely maneuverable.
It's like flying a bus.
No, really.
These are not maneuverable.
Nobody can see them,
but it's still a bus.
So the Air Force
doesn't want this thing.
But DARPA, in the
case of stealth,
working with Lockheed--
which does some fascinating
translation of actually
Russian scientific literature
and develops the
concept of stealth--
and then DARPA jumps on it with
Lockheed and his Skunk Works--
works on developing stealth.
It's working on
precision strike.
Completely changes warfare.
In the Gulf War--
which was where all this stuff
got shown and demonstrated,
and that's where this phrase
revolution in military affairs
comes from--
the Russians saw this stuff.
Revolution in military
affairs is their term
for what we pulled off.
They were stunned that
these technologies created
a whole new kind of capability
on the ground for the US
military that was just--
they had no defense against.
We were essentially up against
a Soviet-trained and style army
in the Gulf War in Iraq,
and their air defense system
fell apart in a very
short period of time.
They could not
deal with stealth.
They could not deal with drones.
This continuous battlefield
awareness, the airline battle
doctrine that was enabled by
these different technologies
created an entirely different
kind of military force.
So DARPA's doing this
stuff, but this stuff
gets stood up
within the military.
It's hard to think what
the civilian application--
we're now working away
in civilian applications
on drones, so that's
transferring over.
That could be
pretty interesting.
It's already starting
to get interesting.
GPS is another part of
that story that's already
long since transferred
over, that DARPA
works on helping to nurture.
Maybe stealth will
transfer over,
because if we do something
resembling autonomous vehicles,
you really want inverse stealth
so that the radar systems can
really see your vehicle,
that they're not
going to miss you in the noise.
Cars could look a lot weirder
if they go stealth, but--
inverse stealth,
but that may be what
we need to do in order to
make these autonomous vehicle
systems really operable.
AUDIENCE: Oh, you're
saying autonomous cars.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yeah, autonomous cars.
I'm sorry.
Not drones-- cars.
AUDIENCE: I was
thinking, why would you
want your drones to be visible?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yeah, so you'd
have a car that looks like
the other side of stealth.
The military is a legacy sector.
It's been around since 1787.
It's extremely
resistant to change.
It has its routines
and doctrines,
and it has its doctrines
that govern how it fights
and so forth.
And then here are Perry,
and Brown, and DARPA
landing in the
middle, forcing them
to adopt completely
disruptive technologies
from what they've been doing.
So DARPA's operating here as
a change agent within a legacy
sector military.
It's able to do the change
agent role because of the island
bridge model.
Remember, we talked
about this at Xerox PARC.
DARPA's got a bridge to
the Secretary of Defense,
and the Secretary of
Defense is able to make
it stick with the military.
And that's a really
key DARPA capability.
That's also a lesson
about how to bring change
into legacy sectors.
So DARPA rules of
small and flexible,
and it's a flat
organization, and it
allows a lot of
freedom and autonomy
outside bureaucratic impediments
to its program managers.
And it has an incredibly
talented technical staff,
and it works off
the challenge model.
The end of a project is
the end of the project.
DARPA shuts things down.
It just doesn't
persevere forever.
If it doesn't seem to be
working, it'll close it down.
It's got all those rules
sets, but in addition, it's
got some other
capabilities that I
think are important to
understanding how to bring
change into legacy sectors.
Form critical innovation
institutions--
that's a lesson that
we're seeing here.
The Defense Department
would not have
done the revolution
in military affairs
if there wasn't a critical
innovation system there
to do the innovation, ie DARPA.
So that's kind of a new rule
for us to think about right.
What's going to be that
critical innovation system that
can operate as a change agent?
Because most of the
economy is legacy sectors.
Point two, use this
island-bridge model.
It's really critical.
Remember, Edison can
call up JP Morgan
and get JP Morgan to fund
the electrical system.
That island-bridge thing
is absolutely critical.
Get your innovation team
on a protected island,
make sure they
have a route back.
And DARPA's a great
example of that.
Build a thinking community--
that's what the
Licklider story is about.
This is not just
Licklider having a vision.
He's able to create a whole
thought community within DARPA
and then by all the people
that are working for DARPA,
like Doug angle and that
whole world out there.
So they're able to scale
up this community so
that it reaches a
certain kind of mass,
and it can get a lot of stuff
done and a lot of thinking
done, and develop a lot
and nurture a lot of ideas.
So when you're thinking about
implementing your technologies,
think about building
that thinking community.
And then another key piece here
is linking the technologies
to the operators.
So if the technologists are
only talking to themselves
and they are not
talking to the people
actually operating the
system, nothing will happen.
So you've got to
make sure, as you're
working on bringing
your technologies about,
that you've got linkages
to the actual operators.
So these are a few more
lessons from DARPA.
And look, I'm going to go
ahead and do Glenn Fong here,
because he's got
some pieces about.
And Max, you've
got Glenn, right?
OK.
Glenn just kind of tells us
what we talked about earlier,
that so much of
the IT revolution
really came out of this
DARPA-supported thinking
community.
So Glenn argues that the
Apple Lisa, and then its Mac
really came from Xerox PARC's
Alto, as we've discussed.
And then in turn,
Microsoft's Windows really
came from Apple's Mac,
which in turn, came back
from Xerox PARC, which in turn
came from this DARPA community.
So the key staff
from PARC go to Apple
and to Microsoft as implementers
on the pieces of the vision
that they're pursuing.
And it's all Lick's kids.
It's this community that
Licklider starts to establish.
So Bob Taylor, as Luyao
led us through last week,
he leads PARC.
The DARPA-funded
university research
centers at places like MIT,
and Berkeley, and Stanford,
and Carnegie Mellon,
and SRI, and Utah,
they support and train a lot
of that Xerox PARC staff.
So by creating the early
computer science departments
and funding them, DARPA's
training a whole thinking
community here.
And this is just a list of
famous computer scientists
that got their
support from DARPA.
And this is who did it.
This is that community.
And it's a stunning
set of realizations
as to just how central DARPA
is at the whole follow-on
to the IT revolution.
So Glenn Fong brings us to
this set of realizations.
Things like Ed Catmull at Lucas
Films, it's a remarkable--
you see where the strands
lead in off and all kinds
of directions.
So you get a sense
for just how--
what a great foundational
institution this is.
So let's do some questions
and points about these two
readings.
And Rasheed, do you
want to lead us off
on that chapter
from the textbook?
And then we'll go to Max.
RASHEED: Yeah.
So I think it's really
important in this chapter.
as it highlights the
elements of DARPA that
make it so fantastic and able
to do all the things it's
been able to do.
So we talked about
the island-bridge,
and things like that--
but really the success of
also the program managers
acting as sort of
mini change agents
to be able to be that
small and flexible.
I think somebody asked actually
a pretty good question, which
was, is there a way to bring
these elements of DARPA--
giving these dynamic
program managers
the freedom to do the things
that they want to do--
is there a way to do that
outside of this DARPA model,
maybe enterprise to this model?
I think Martin
asked that question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RASHEED: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Yeah, I just thought it was
really interesting, because
in business, a lot
of time, you talk
about focusing on the alphas
and getting rid of your betas.
The stuff that you're
really, really good at,
focus on doing that, so if
you're not good don't do it.
So you try to
outsource everything.
So it'd be an interesting model
because you might move faster.
And so that's what
I was thinking
about-- a way of people
with good ideas that
are very capable being
linked with resources
in a much better manner to
maybe being able to do more.
AUDIENCE: So I just
want to interject.
I think you just
described the MIT faculty.
We can hire postdocs
and students
to do things that might not
want to do, and they specialize.
AUDIENCE: The way I would
think about it differently is--
that would mean they're
very book smart.
And like what kind of
person would come into--
through MIT faculty versus
like people that might be--
look at the people--
Apple-- Steve Jobs--
drop out-- Bill Gates--
drop out.
You're definitely right,
but I guess the way
I was trying to say it is more--
AUDIENCE: You don't
have to say that.
AUDIENCE: Well, you are right.
I meant more of a spectrum
of personality types.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
it's interesting,
because I don't know--
you guys see the
research that they do.
A lot of these faculty
that I come across
have spin out companies.
And no, they're not all
becoming Bill Gates overnight,
but they're all very much
into their own specialty.
AUDIENCE: Well,
the research model
is a very productive model
because you have somebody
who has key insights but didn't
have the time to go and make
a company off of it,
so you get somebody
from-- who's one of
their grad students.
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the professor [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Oh god, which one?
Langer?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: But also,
research institutions
try to focus more on--
they're called frog innovations,
[INAUDIBLE] you move forward.
And so I was thinking more
of hawk innovations, which
is a completely different field
that no one's looking into,
because it doesn't seem
to be that productive.
AUDIENCE: OK.
There are a bunch of frogs,
is that what you're saying?
AUDIENCE: No, no.
Just in general the type of
research that goes through.
Or it has to have a purpose
that's already defined
based on a current paradigm.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So it's very risky
to do anything different
because you're kind of ruining
your thesis [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And have to get money
from somebody to do it,
and convince them
it's going somewhere.
Yeah, OK.
Got it.
RASHEED: How does
that fit in with what
you were saying with
the alphas and betas,
where focus in on what
you're good at [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: I think the idea
that he's trying to get at
is that you focus on
what you're good at,
but in order to figure
out what you're good at,
you have to have some
failures along the way.
So you have to try and
do different things,
and then maybe you find out, oh,
this idea's really amazing he.
It'll make lots
of money, and it--
and we happen to know
what we're doing.
But you might have
a dozen things
that don't go so well before
that, so it's a process.
AUDIENCE: You might come up
with the key insight, in terms
of manufacturing,
but you haven't
done large-scale manufacturing.
So how are you going to
connect to a firm that already
understands that really well so
that you can execute quickly?
So you try to figure it out.
But it'll take you
a lot of capital,
will take you two to three
years and you're screwed.
I was thinking more of like--
in software, you have
Amazon Web Services,
you have databases that are
already huge that you can just
go port and you're through.
And it'd be interesting for
that for like manufacturing
or biology.
Because also biology's
super difficult,
because say you want to
do a startup [INAUDIBLE]
RASHEED: Yeah.
So I guess obviously it's going
to vary along different fields,
but I think manufacturing might
be an interesting one, or even
biology and the
intricacies there.
But I think this brings
up a larger point, which
is an even bigger
abstract question,
but follows along with this
idea of creating these change
agents.
And so somebody asked, is there
this sense that these change
agents, like the ones
that are found in DARPA--
is it important to
create these change
agents by giving you a whole
bunch of money and letting do
you do--
use your own discretion,
as product managers,
to figure out what you
want to do, or to find
these people that are
doing these fringe research
opportunities that
might be high risk,
and they might not just have
the funding, and go from there?
And so it's the do you
want to create these change
agents by giving
it to the people
that you think are capable, or
do you want to go out and find
these people who may not be
proven in their field yet,
or might not have research
that is still at this high risk
phase?
STEPH: Could I ask
clarifying question?
Do you mean in the
context of DARPA,
or do you mean generally?
RASHEED: I would say
generally, because DARPA--
you have a model that's
established already.
STEPH: OK.
The reason I ask that
is because in one
of the readings for today--
I believe it was the--
it might have been the
Fong reading actually--
there's a quote from
that technologist who
said that he wanted
the government
to not touch engineers at all.
He said, "If the US wants
[INAUDIBLE] jobs, better lives,
and a stronger economy,
the best thing lobbyist
bureaucrats and politicians
can do is leave us alone."
And so that's why I
thought it was interesting
if you were asking in
the context of DARPA
or in the context of an
organization that was funded
by government dollars.
Because maybe what
the implication
is, in this instance,
for this person who
is rejecting the notion
that government played
any role in the computational
revolution of all,
is we don't want
government help.
But maybe the model
that they actually want
is give us the money, and then
don't mess with us at all.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
STEPH: Yeah, exactly.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
That's spoken
like someone who's done
some annual reports before.
AUDIENCE: Is that the VC?
Is that from [INAUDIBLE]?
STEPH: This is from Draper.
AUDIENCE: Draper?
STEPH: It's on
page 234, if you're
interested in looking at it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
I think what
he meant is more like
please don't put more
regulations that I
have to deal with,
when I'm trying to innovate.
It keeps getting in the way.
STEPH: I like Beth's
point too, though.
I'm so sorry, Lily.
I like your point too.
Could you maybe elaborate
in your experience
what it's like to innovate
under the auspices of working
in a team with other people?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so
I've had experience
with National Science
Foundation grants,
huge NASA Astrobiology
Institute grants.
And their reporting
requirements are intensive.
Usually they're on
an annual basis.
And I think that the intention
behind the annual reporting
is necessary and good.
But often, they're
extremely cumbersome,
and the first year, really
people are just making--
including stuff that
they've already done,
or even inflating what
they've accomplished
to look good on the report.
So those are the
only experiences
that I've had is with
those two funding agencies.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think DARPA
has the more [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah,
DARPA runs a different kind
of opposite operation.
There's there's, frankly, less
paper, but the DARPA program
manager--
at a traditional science agency,
the whole decision process
is organized around whether or
not you get the grant award.
And it's getting that
award out the door.
That's how these organizations
are really put together.
That's what the peer review
process and selection
process is built around.
In DARPA, and in the--
excuse me-- in some
of the DARPA clones,
the program manager, that's like
just getting the grant award.
That's only stage one.
Then the program manager
moves into your home.
They're going to be
on you all the time.
Someone has described
DARPA as a set of geniuses
connected by a travel agent.
They spend at least 1/3
of their time on the road
out meeting with their
teams, bringing ideas around.
They'll typically have a
number of teams standing up
working on a portfolio
of related projects,
and they're going to bring ideas
from those different teams.
They're going to put those teams
together to talk to each other,
and sometimes that's not
easy, because they don't want
to really share their secrets.
So it's a complicated
process to manage,
but the DARPA manager
is there to help
the awardee get
through the process
and work in any way possible
to expedite things and move
things along.
So it's a completely
different organizational model
for the program manager compared
to most science agencies.
And the DARPA clones,
like ARPA-E or IARPA
do the same thing.
And we'll talk about
ARPA-E at a later class.
But it's just a different model.
And there's another capability--
we talked earlier about DARPA
capability of working at
both the institutional level
and at the great groups level.
The purpose of this
reading about its work
within the defense
legacy sector is
to say that DARPA has
been able to do innovation
within a legacy sector
to a remarkable degree,
as well as do
innovation, like in IT,
on a complete
technology frontier.
That's a remarkable
set of capabilities
to build into one
place, and yet its model
has been able to fit both.
So it's another
interesting achievement
that it's been able to pull off.
AUDIENCE: Just to go back to--
I know in your book,
you talk about how,
when you go to a
legacy sector, it's
like you're parachuting down
and they're shooting at you.
I think, for the military
[INAUDIBLE] fields
and new areas, it might easier,
and so it's easier to form.
But I think for energy, how
do you make that distinction?
Because I feel
other legacy sectors
would be a lot
harder to come in.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Well, the military's
a hard legacy sector,
because remember,
the services have the money.
They have their
procurement budgets.
And if they don't want to
do it, it's really hard
to get them to do it.
So that's why that island-bridge
model's so crucial for DARPA
being able to rely on
the Secretary of Defense
to kind of override
some of the directions
where the services want to go.
It's still not easy, but all of
these three technology areas--
position strike,
UAVs, and stealth--
were all stood up despite some
pretty significant service
opposition.
Not uniformly-- different
parts of the services
saw what the possibilities were,
so I want to make that uniform.
But it was still tough.
These were not
easy to implement.
AUDIENCE: So
[INAUDIBLE] so would you
say that ARPA-E has been
as successful [INAUDIBLE]
DARPA did, or how do
you think about it?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah,
we'll go through ARPA-E
when we get to that class, but
I think ARPA-E is very young.
It's still very new.
AUDIENCE: Like 2009, right?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah,
it's like seven years old.
So in some ways, the
jury's still out,
and we'll see if they survive.
But looks very interesting.
So Max, let's do some
of Glenn Fong's work.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, sure.
OK, so basically,
Fong was talking
a lot about PARC,
and Xerox, and how
a lot of the concepts that
were developed at PARC
were eventually taken
by Microsoft and Apple,
and basically created the
PC revolution that we all
know and love.
Yeah, Apple fanboy.
So one of the questions
that I had while I
was reading the Fong reading--
maybe someone can clarify this--
I didn't really
understand-- so PARC's--
a lot of their
ideas were taken--
virtually everything--
so how did PARC not
respond in any
sort of legal way?
They could have sued.
Was it possibly because
they didn't patent anything?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: [INAUDIBLE]
Jobs bought the rights--
AUDIENCE: OK.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
--to go through.
So he acquired those rights.
AUDIENCE: I thought it was just
the rights to visit, or the--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Do you know?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So I don't know if
it was he bought the rights.
I know he funded them somehow.
And part of that
funding was that, oh,
I get to check
out your projects,
and I get to see [INAUDIBLE]
and take those ideas how it is.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: I'll
clarify this later.
But he can do that
because of the rights.
And then Gates could
do it because--
Jobs and Gates were friends,
so Jobs showed Gates.
He's like, look at this
cool thing I'm doing.
Because they're kind of
in a different sectors.
So he's like, check it out.
What do you think?
Because he's trying
to impress his friend,
who's also very successful.
And Gates is like, whoa,
this is pretty great.
And then he goes and he
copies, and he [INAUDIBLE]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: You're
talking about Windows?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So he comes out with--
was it Windows DOS?
He comes out with that
right before [INAUDIBLE]----
because this is going to be
part of the new Apple Computer.
And he comes out
with it right before,
so it looks like Gates
did it, instead of Jobs.
And then Jobs literally
goes like, we're done.
This is the reason Apple
became so secretive.
They used to be a lot more open.
They became secretive because
after that, he's like--
any little thing can go
out if somebody finds out,
we're not doing this anymore.
So it completely
switched the hierarchy.
So that's the rights
part, in terms of the--
Jobs does it, and then
when Gates copies--
when Jobs takes
Gates to court, Gates
can say, actually, we both
stole it, but it's OK for him,
so it's OK for me.
[INAUDIBLE]
RASHEED: But like you just
said, Jobs didn't steal it.
He paid for it.
He paid for the rights.
AUDIENCE: When they
go to court, Gates
says, yeah, we both just
took it from the same source.
It's not like it was
originally Apple's.
So that's the element
of the legality.
The second part--
the reason PARC
wouldn't do it is because
you have this thing called
the innovator's dilemma,
which is, in any company,
you can have a product line--
a great example's Kodak.
They came out with the
first digital camera,
but you're already
making so much money,
and you probably have a
large revenue streams doing--
taking pictures of Polaroids.
So this is like, if you're
an Ethernet company--
if you're 3Com, and
you have these--
you're putting wires everywhere.
It's not the next
day it's like, yo, we
got to take all this out.
Another thing too is, once
you become a public company,
every single quarter matters.
So you can never go back.
You can know you're wrong
but you have to go forward,
or else you're just
going to get kicked off
or you're going to get
sued by shareholders.
It's a very complicated
thing to do.
RASHEED: Also, I wonder how
much PARC staff or Xerox staff
there is left to really benefit
after all the staff is actually
just going to Apple and
Microsoft afterward.
It's not that I didn't
benefit because I was at Xerox
and I missed the wave.
It's like.
I just left Xerox to go
work at Apple or Microsoft,
and then got the benefits later.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So Luyao,
you led us through Xerox PARC
very nicely last week.
Do you have thoughts on
how come Xerox didn't
get the Alto, and
personal computing,
and graphic interfaces,
and the mouse out the door?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] last
week that they were
so much into the research
they're doing, and so
passion that they
didn't consider
commercializing or bringing it
to the general audience at all.
One of the investors came
to their meeting room
and sat on a beanbag saying,
OK, I'm the person [INAUDIBLE]
Can you guys show me more, and
I will commercialize all this
by making it possible?
But they didn't.
They totally ignored him.
So I think they had a
chance, but they just
didn't the awareness, I think.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
It was a really serious
island-bridge connection
problem.
AUDIENCE: They were probably
missing one or two [INAUDIBLE]
in their group that
were able to connect
with the market with
their innovations.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Part of this is
something Martin
mentioned earlier,
which is Xerox was focused
on its core competency, which
is photocopies.
And they didn't understand this
explosion of personal computing
capability, because it didn't
fit their core competency
model.
So they missed a
staggering opportunity.
But fortunately, Jobs saved
us, so it all worked out.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] call
it the beanbag effect.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Too
much time in those beanbags,
is that your point, Lily?
Right, that was a
great photograph
of the crowd on beanbags.
You had a great
picture for us, Luyao.
How about a closing
thought, Max, on Fong--
or a couple of closing thoughts?
AUDIENCE: Let's see.
How about a closing question?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Sure.
AUDIENCE: All right.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: That's fine.
I only let you get one
out, so it's all yours.
AUDIENCE: So one
of the questions
that someone had previously
mentioned this basically
there's this stereotype that
government bureaucracy is
kind of slow, and sluggish,
and full of red tape,
and it's horrible.
And is it possible
that you could use--
like DARPA as an
example-- to say
that maybe this is unfounded,
maybe it's not as realistic
as people think?
And to continue that--
there's a couple of parts
to this question--
is it unfounded,
and should the government
try to redo its image,
for lack of a better phrase?
And is there really any
advantage they can get from it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: What?
Can you repeat [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, sorry.
I know, I started
rambling a little bit.
Is the government slow?
AUDIENCE: Is DARPA an
instance where it's not slow?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
And does the government
get any advantage
from making itself
not look slow?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: That's a
really important point, Max.
DARPA is stuck in one of the
most notorious bureaucracies
on the planet, that
dates back to like 1787.
So how is it able
to do this stuff?
It has some very interesting
rules and some capabilities
that it got.
One of its key rules is that--
it's called other
transactions authority.
And DARPA's argument is, look,
we're not buying jet aircraft.
We're just buying what's in
people's heads to do research.
So we don't have
to go through all
that elaborate
procurement process
to protect the taxpayers.
We're out of the Federal
Procurement System.
So DARPA's able to contract
with enormous freedom,
and very quickly.
And then another DARPA
power that they've acquired
is that they can--
they have what's
called IPA authority--
Intergovernmental
Personnel Act authority.
So ironically, at
one point, DARPA
was attempting to hire me.
And I don't know
why they wanted me,
because I'm not a technologist,
but they seemed to want this.
And I wasn't going
to go to DARPA,
because I'm not a technologist.
I wouldn't be at the
heart of the operation.
So it wasn't going to work.
But they said they
can hire me in a day.
They said, you want to do this?
You're on tomorrow.
This Intergovernmental
Personnel Act
enables them
essentially to enter
into a contract with
whatever organization
you're working for--
maybe it's a university.
They buy your services using
this other transactions
authority, so that they
can put you on the job
almost immediately.
The use this IPA authority with
companies or with universities
to be able to hire in
lickety-split time.
Corporations can't hire this
fast, much less universities,
much less government.
So they're outside of two
of the traditional banes
of governmental
bureaucratic nightmares.
They got themselves
free of that authority.
And interestingly, both ARPA-E
and IARPA, the DARPA clones,
have the same capabilities.
So that's part of why they're
able to act like this.
I don't think it's
the whole story,
but that's a couple
of pieces that they've
been able to acquire.
RASHEED: I would
answer and say, I
guess, traditionally,
you would say
government and bureaucracy
[INAUDIBLE] the highlight
of what's slow is.
When you think of
something slow,
you think of a congressional
session or something like that.
STEPH: It's deliberate.
RASHEED: And it's
deliberately so,
and then there's an entire
argument that can get into.
Is government
supposed to move slow
because they need to be this
giant political machine that
shouldn't be swayed by just
one charismatic convincing guy?
But anyway, I think it's
important to understand
that DARPA doesn't move
slow because often it
doesn't have this
opportunity to,
for national security reasons.
It's just not prudent for
us to move slow to develop,
I guess, like drones
and things like that,
which might have been drastic--
things would look
drastically different
if someone else
had done it first,
or if we went into the Gulf
War without these capabilities.
STEPH: Transferring that example
to something like genomics,
could you imagine the
kinds of implications
that it could have on just
fundamental human ethics
if they were able to create
genetic engineering overnight
in the way that DARPA's
been able to create things?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Well, I do want
to tell you that DARPA
now has a very strong
biological technologies office.
So look out, Steph.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
STEPH: Oh, yeah.
Well, it was interesting,
because at the AAAS meeting
in February, one of the sessions
that I went to-- actually with
Chuck Weiss, who is
Bill's co-author for many
of the things--
was a panel that included this
guy named Gary Marchant who's
a lawyer ethicist and genomics
engineer, who was talking
about the necessity to
include a participatory ethics
in decision making for genomics.
And one of his primary
arguments, as I recall it,
is truly that, if
we want to have--
if we want to do a good
job of implementing this
at scale, nationally
or globally,
we also have to do a good
job of listening meaningfully
to populations and
then, at the same time,
meaningfully incorporating their
feedback into their creation
process.
And that's very difficult. And
I think that's precisely why
government is slow-- or the
word that I choose use--
deliberate-- but it obviously
does make innovation.
So to Max's point, I don't
think that DARPA applies,
unfortunately, to most things.